it over to Alli well LeBron does taking
over in the fourth ever get old
no uh as money time I've been there a
lot in my career and I understand the
assignment so I was happy I was able to
make a couple plays but big shot came
from AR up one take us up four that was
big time no question 7.4 seconds on the
clock one possession game what are you
reinforcing your team in that timeout um
well we got to execute one like I said
AR got the shot and then uh we had to
come down here and protect not give up a
three being up four KD made a heck of a
reverse layup but we was able to get the
ball in let's execute try to make both
free throws ad went one for two and uh I
actually I wanted to foul because of the
shooting ability by Katie and book um
but we didn't get an opportunity and uh
Katie was look a wi right there's always
a million scenarios at any point in time
you know them all so my final question
to you is you've won a championship
you've been an MVP a final MVP and
Olympic gold medalist what would an NBA
cup adding to that list of trophies mean
to you LeBron it is what it is I mean
it's inauguration it is what it is at
this point in the season um we have an
opportunity to compete for something so
why not I mean you got the greatest
competitors in the world fighting for
something so let's fight we'll see you
in Vegas all right perfect thank you
thank you and I think you just nailed it
it's competition that's right